but what i found about the hispanic
audiences because i would only perform
you know in the beginning with
they really did embrace me as soon as i
would come i mean they would yell out
stuff
like cochino and all this stuff like
that right right but it was still like
you know
all in fun and whatnot but i you know i
went to the i was like
i went to the latino laugh festival they
invited me we're in san antonio right
i remember me and joey diaz went over
there we had no money we
begged managers to buy us meals because
we couldn't eat but it was like
you know all that early experience you
know i mean was just so
vital for me dude because you know in
the beginning you know these white clubs
wouldn't have me
they just wouldn't you know and then
it's as soon as i
they wouldn't so if you called the place
or they wouldn't sign you up or they
would wouldn't audition no you would go
to the improv and it's like you wouldn't
you weren't a regular and you couldn't
you didn't even know who to talk to
right because they didn't have the
friend that knew
right so iowa aisle he did was like was
like you know
the the hispanic nights or the comedy
store because i was a doorman there but
you know
it's as soon as i in 1990 2000 i did
leno and i got mad tv right like in a
year and then all of a sudden clubs were
like
all right you're here i mean you had to
at that point
sure right you had to get credit and
then they were like come on in
so but but how long do i mean because
like you don't give a [ __ ]
and that's and a lot of committees all
they do is give a [ __ ]
so when when i would see you right
they're like
so you this [ __ ] was like no
shirt on [ __ ] naked [ __ ] thong
you're just like this [ __ ]
it's so crazy that you're like how can
you not [ __ ] love this dude like
already latinos love you like when the
el cacino that's like
yeah yeah standing up and that that's
that's what you want
um so i can see it you know i can see it
but also
to get out of your own way takes [ __ ]
20 years yeah and you did it
in a in five [ __ ] years like i don't
know i don't know how it was
it was probably five six years yeah
where you got out of your way faster
because
nobody tells you got to get out of your
own way
i think you find it but then you however
your process
was like you're like i'm i'm not gonna
give a [ __ ] early and that's
i think when you think about how time we
waste so much time
guys don't get better yeah yeah guys
don't get better they're around
and they're around a long time and
they're not better or they're not
different
you were different and better every time
somebody saw you well the the i think
the most important thing was is that
not only was i asian but there was i'm
not you know i mean
i'm a specific there wasn't an asian
like me
right like authentically like me like i
think that's why when i first met him
like
a decade ago or eight years ago yeah i
was like
that one that asian is so [ __ ] up
that's the one i want like i was like i
i don't
i don't i don't relate to the do-gooders
like i didn't you know the just by
virtue even telling people you're asian
automatically they put you in a box of
being like
a model minority and all of this stuff
so when i saw this [ __ ] just
like
half naked at the comedy store i was
like i want that one
can i tell you something okay listen i'm
gonna be 60 april 23rd yeah
in my life i have never
heard a i would say latina filipina
all across all of it together any woman
say
that when she saw a guy and he was
[ __ ] up that they say
that's the one
i swear to god
because because if if women would just
[ __ ] understand that you're [ __ ] up
and try and let you be [ __ ] up but
you'll come home
like you'll be so much better remember i
grew up boxing as a kid
like i between him and i like making out
with [ __ ] deals
but yeah yeah but whatever whatever it
is you know what that's a [ __ ]
beautiful thing because
judgment doesn't go away when [ __ ]
people judge you they they
they might say oh you know i'm very
non-judgmental then someone parks in
their [ __ ] driveway they're like
you [ __ ] went back it's gonna [ __ ]
you and it just comes out
yeah but you know that it's a it's
yeah it's great you know when you were
mentioning earlier about
your rise and stuff like that and i just
i kind of like you know
it's almost